in just five episodes the first volume
of the long-awaited third season of
Netflix is The Witcher packs in a
considerable amount of story all that
plot means not everyone likely caught
all the callbacks and references and
there are plenty warning spoilers for
The Witcher season 3 volume 1 to come
the third season of The Witcher opens
with a montage and catches viewers up on
what the series is Central Trio geralt
Siri and yennefer have been up to since
leaving care Morin at the end of season
2. geralt and Jennifer are shown to be
working together to help keep Siri
hidden and help her learn to control her
magic unfortunately geralt still hasn't
forgiven yennefer for nearly giving
Syria to the deathless mother and
refuses to communicate with her directly
so the audience is treated to Jennifer's
voiceover as she narrates the letter as
she writes to her former lover each
letter begins with the phrase dear
friend at first this might not seem like
an unusual way to start a letter the
universe sarcastic delivery of the line
and each voiceover suggests that there
might be more to this phrasing than
meets the eye
dear friend
the phrase is indeed a direct callback
to the season 2 episode dear friend in
which geralt and Jennifer are finally
reunited for the first time since
Universe assumed death
run
dear friend
Jennifer is surprised by the term
offended even given their long history
as lovers
the third season's first episode also
finds Yas gear being thrown out by a
woman he cheated on as he's tossed out
on the streets he's eventually
approached by the dwarf yarpin who
geralt sent to enlist his help European
seems annoyed that he has to deal with
yaskir again and the two exchange quips
until yaskir makes a mention of the rule
of threes
it's a rule of Threes think it has to be
done this is not just a cheeky nod to
the fact that yaskir is a writer but
also a reference to this being the third
time that the two would be working
together the first time geralt and
yaskir teamed up with yarpin is in the
season one episode rare species where he
and his band of Dwarven warriors were
among the four teams that were sent out
to hunt the green dragon for King
needhamir jarpin and his team begin as
Rivals to geralt in yaskir but they
ultimately worked together in Europe and
befriends geralt in the season 2 episode
bolith mayor geralten yaskir enlist
yarpin's crew after serious kidnapped by
Jennifer garpin accompanies the two
until Syria is safely backed the geralt
in the second episode of season three
Unbound geralt and yaskir visits the
detective agency Cod ringer and Pen to
purchase information on riennese a
fire-wielding mage who has been hunting
Siri relentlessly to try and determine
who he might be working for geralt meets
with Alice codringer who initially tries
to squeeze more money out of the Witcher
for the info but geralt outsmarts the
detective who then starts giving up what
he knows cutteringer mentions a visit
from isthred referring back to a scene
from the show's second season episode
dear friend after learning that Siri was
able to destroy a monolith istrad
visited the detective agency in hopes of
learning more about the situation he
discovered that a particular Gene
leshard rather Laura kept appearing in
the women of the Cintron Royal bloodline
and that it may be the key to how she
was able to destroy the monolith
gear has quickly become a fan favorite
character thanks in no small part to
actor Joey bady's performance not only
does a character have great chemistry
with geralt and add a unique and comedic
Dynamic to the cast but he also sings
several original songs with deep ties to
his relationship with geralt these songs
have proven very popular among much of
The Witcher fan base taking on a sort of
Life of their own s gear has an even
bigger role in season 3 than in previous
Seasons following geralt and Company on
many of their Adventures he also strikes
up an interesting relationship with
radovoid the prince of redania
throughout the season yaskir wears a
shirt with a floral print no doubt a
reference to the character's name in the
English translations of author Andre
sapkowski's novels and the video games
yes gear goes by the name dandelion
Netflix chose to keep the character's
polish name which translates more
closely to Buttercup
The Season's second episode reintroduces
audiences to Tris Marigold series former
mentor and one of Jennifer's fellow
sorceresses it's revealed that Tris
hasn't yet returned to King full test
Court in temeria despite some members of
the Brotherhood urging her to do so she
has instead remained at aratuza tasaya
has continued to protect her and given
her a role at the school as a teacher
Tris is briefly seen teaching a lesson
to a group of students eagle-eyed
viewers might notice some familiar
elements of this particular lesson each
student has a branch of daisy flowers
and a rock in their hands so they're
likely for the levitation incantation in
which the life force of the flowers is
drained in order to lift the rock the
incantation spoken in order to lift the
rock is zelil ape which an elder speech
translates to rise up this is one of the
first Lessons yennefer Learned in the
first season and remains one of the most
important in her mind after losing her
ability to use magic in season 2 the
universe attempted to recite Zelo ape
and the deathless mother's lair
damn it
after parting ways with geralt at the
end of The Season's first episode Siri
and Jennifer try to lay low as they
slowly make their way to aratuza
rienover hopes that taseya will help
train Siri to control her magic while
stopped at a local Tavern Siri bumps
into a courier that wishes her safe
travels Siri then sees a vision of his
impending death the Courier's name is
never mentioned in the show but fans of
the books know this as Apple cath a
royal messenger for demaven the king of
ederm his mission is to bring back
correspondence from sigismund dixtra of
rodania his death while seemingly a
small and unimportant moment creates
major ripples throughout the northern
kingdoms because of a letter he was
unable to deliver there's another small
hint of what is to come when The Courier
visits rodania and attends King
vizimir's party the king fires an arrow
and jest and a whizzes past Applegate's
face hitting the wall just in front of
him
in The Season's third episode reunion
yennefer and Siri make another stop on
their way to aratuza this time in the
town of gorz velen Jennifer wants to
reach to Saya but has to split up with
Siri to do so she brings Siri to the
John cardi bank which is run by a local
dwarf named molar John carty Molnar is
indebted to yennefer because she once
saved his family so he agrees to watch
after Siri he places Siri in the care of
his assistant Fabio sacks while she
explores the city during her exploration
Siri happens upon a painting of the
tower at aratusa Fabio tells her about
the painting while also telling her
stories about the famed Academy for
Mages in particular he tells that he
heard about some students that got
turned into eels although this may be a
mere Legend of Fabio audiences will know
that his story is indeed true it was
confirmed in the season 1 episode 4
marks where Jennifer sees to Saya turn
three of her underperforming students
into eels to help power aratusa's Magic
Jennifer is ultimately able to contact
to Saya and arrange to have Siri brought
to aratuza to study magic when Siri is
brought before to Saya they have an
interesting interaction Siri clearly
intimidated by Jennifer's longtime
Mentor looks at jennifer with a pleading
stare while to say a grabs her face and
examines her viewers with a good memory
might find to say his next line to be
eerily familiar she says
don't look at her
look at me
this scene mirrors Jennifer's first
meeting with desea years before where
Jennifer looks to her mother for help is
to say a visor from her father Siri
looks to Jennifer indicating that she
may be beginning to see Jennifer as a
surrogate mother a thing that will
continue throughout the season
many of the characters in The Witcher
have grown and evolved quite a bit since
the first season but few have come
nearly as far as kahir a high-ranking
nilf guardian intelligence officer and
one of Emperor amir's most trusted
allies in season one he was charged with
capturing princess cirilla of sintra and
bringing her back to Amir kahir appears
to be a True Believer in the milk
Guardian cause never questioning his
loyalty to Amir or his belief in his
mission despite all of the brutality he
has witnessed and been a part of things
begin to change after kahir is captured
in season 2 though while escaping the
brotherhood's custody and going back to
sintra kahir spends a lot of time hiding
among different groups of people
especially the elves Upon returning he
appears more lenient towards those who
don't align with MILF Guardian beliefs
including the Mage for Angela as the
third season gets going Amir askahir to
kill Gallatin an Elven Warrior he
befriended he carries out the deed but
it becomes apparent that the decision
weighs heavily on him and his loyalty to
Amir could be waning
you said you knew a good leader when you
saw them
how
in the third season's fourth episode the
invitation geralt and Siri trying to
take a ferry to aratuza to attend a Gala
put on by tasaya and the Brotherhood
when they arrive yaskir informs them
that the fairy men refuses to leave
because he is afraid of an unknown
monster lurking in the waters Siri
looking to convince geralt to kill the
monster says
besides
the witches
is that sir the scene is more
significant than it may seem at first
Sirius spent a considerable amount of
time learning how to fight and training
to be more like The Witcher she lived
with at Cameron but this marks the first
time that she has actually referred to
herself as a Witcher she never underwent
the mutation process to possess a
witcher's Powers but she nevertheless
considers herself to be one of them this
isn't stark contrast to the Mages where
Siri shows little interest in aligning
herself with them despite Jennifer's
pleas for her tooth the fifth episode of
the season the art of Illusion pretty
much all takes place during the course
of one night at the ball being held at
aratuza by the Brotherhood and is told
out of order from various perspectives
the ball is meant to align all the
magical advisors against nilfgaard but
geralt and Jennifer have an alternate
agenda hoping to find evidence that
backs their theory that the wizard stray
Gabor is behind riences attacks on Siri
throughout the episode a song sung by a
group of bards is played multiple times
as viewers experience the story's
different perspectives viewers might
notice that the bards regularly repeat
the phrase all is not as it seems this
is a not so subtle allusion to not only
the theme of the entire episode but also
the twist ending stregabore had nothing
to do with Rihanna's attacks it's
vilgafort's a trusted Ally of to Saya
who's the Mastermind behind the evil
plot
vizimir II king of rodania is one of the
major players in the war of the northern
kingdoms that rages throughout the third
season of The Witcher early in the
season vizimir makes plans to capture
Siri to marry her and take control of
sintra which would make him the
strongest King in all of the northern
kingdoms this plan is wholeheartedly
supported by spymaster sigismund
deedstra and a sorceress advisor
Philippa eilhart but after meeting with
nofgar vizimir agrees to hand Siri over
to the invading Kingdom a move that
dijkstra and Isle heart can't abidebar
one of The Season's most shocking
moments comes when vismir receives what
appears to be a gift from nilgard the
box contains the head of his wife Hedwig
making vismir very distraught his
brother radovid discovers that dextra
and Isle heart were responsible for her
death and uses it to blame nilgard for
the attack while the moment comes as a
big surprise the scheming spymaster and
the Sorceress hinted the big move
earlier when she says
perhaps it's time to make it useful to
us